[Music]
q4 of this year is going to be insane
shocktober when you hold up for when
you're playing football fourth quarter
fourth quarter in the fourth quarter
fourth quarter
yeah they had us the first half i'm not
gonna lie fourth quarter baby they had
us the whole game but it's all about the
fourth quarter fourth quarter fourth
quarter
this is your time
their time
is done
the chairman of the federal reserve
explicitly saying no intention to ban
bitcoin obviously bitcoin is going wild
on the internet el salvador has started
to mine bitcoin using energy from
volcano the apex predator of the
financial markets is ready to roll you
play to win the game
hello you play to win the game going to
the fourth quarter of the football game
but they are what we thought they were
and we let them off the hook we can
fight our way back
into the light
we can climb out of hell we will not go
quietly into the night
and remember what got you here focus on
the fundamentals we've gone over time
and time again we can't be consumed by
our petty differences anymore
[Music]
we will be united in our common interest
we have won every single game we have
played till now
so this team
is perfect
we'll give us a little four figures in
the air for the fourth quarter
how we gonna finish it how are we gonna
close it out fourth quarter
[Music]
good morning good morning good morning
welcome back to the best business show
why is it the best because we said it
was i'm here with my brothers joe with
john
this is the show that we wish that we
had we were learning about business
investing in finance how do you know
their names are joe and john real simple
their names are on the back of their
chairs joe taking off the rounds
lots of free bitcoin but no free ads you
guys already know how we get down here's
the deal today we are gonna go for the
biggest show we've ever had we need your
help the show is free the content's free
the jokes are free all we need you to do
is smash the like button we're already
at 333 likes we will give away 250
dollars worth of bitcoin every single
time we cross another 500 like milestone
we hit 500 likes 250 bucks we cross over
a thousand 250 bucks a bitcoin cross
over 1500 250 bucks and we'll continue
if we get all the way to 10 000 likes we
will have given away 250 of bitcoin
every single time your job is to smash
the like button our job is to educate
and entertain you so that's what we're
gonna do today before we forget so far
if we're going to have the best business
show we need to have the best partner
sofi.com you go there you create an
account you can do everything from
refinance your student loans buy stocks
buy pre-ipo stocks you can also buy
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies if you buy
bitcoin on sofi you go you buy ten
dollars worth of bitcoin they'll give
you ten dollars for free but breaking
news we just crossed 500 likes today's
gonna be a lot of fun because then plan
b is going to come on the show when plan
b comes on the show i'm pretty sure that
he's gonna drop knowledge on stock to
flow model where he thinks bitcoin's
going by the end of the year and he
might even give us a little bit of
inside secrets into new things that he's
been working on to start off the first
250
what i want in the chat leave a comment
with what did you do this weekend what
were your weekend plans what did you do
we're gonna pick somebody right now live
250 bucks in bitcoin on the show john
are you ready boom are you ready let's
get it john and joe have been hyped for
today last night we were texting trying
to pick topics and we said let's just go
for it let's go for the biggest show
we've ever had yeah i mean bitcoin's
ripping we're ripping it's gonna be a
good week all right what do we got john
you're picking the winner so let's hurry
up and uh uh start trying to pick the
winner i'm gonna go into a little update
on bitcoin john's gonna have a winner
for us when we get done with this first
section plan b coming on at noon you
already know that today is going to be a
big one so keep smashing the like button
i have got a winner oh john's already
got a winner let's go we're not let's
get it let's go car uh carlo gal
k
k-a-r-l-o
g-a-l-e had a birthday party so
to help you out so congrats carlos let's
uh but let's see if we can get to a
thousand likes before the first topic i
think we're pretty close we're already
at almost 700. wow oh you oh you're
going big i mean like let's do we never
got 2 000 before the first topic that's
another 250 of bitcoin smash it
all right well we're waiting for that to
happen i'm going to go on and then joe
will pick the next winner no faith
bitcoin is absolutely ripping we cross
over 57 000 this morning and when you
start to look at the underlying data it
is telling us that it is likely to go
much much higher through the end of the
year when we actually look at the first
chart that we have here bitcoin over 57
500 it's up about four percent today the
first thing that jumps out to me when we
look at these charts is that now a four
percent move in bitcoin means that
bitcoin is moving thousands of dollars
in a single day likely we will start to
see ten percent movements as well but a
four percent leap much much more
volatile than anything else in this
chart s p gold silver euro yen renin b
or the oil now on top of this people
always argue that bitcoin is too
volatile that is one of the critiques
from the critics but what they failed to
mention is that bitcoin's volatility
works in both directions if you are
holding bitcoin and bitcoin is volatile
to the downside it hurts you it's a
negative but if you are holding bitcoin
and bitcoin is volatile to the upside
the volatility is your friend and that's
what we're watching right here 2
227 increase in the price of bitcoin
over the last 24 hours volatility is
good when it goes in your favor when we
start to look at the actual underlying
metrics of the uh
network you can see the bitcoin market
cap is over one trillion dollars 1.08
trillion dollars as of this morning on
top of that the inflation rate still is
at one point seven eight percent well
below the fed's target of two percent in
the u.s dollar system the supply issued
89.7
bitcoin settlement volume has topped 11
billion
one day last week bitcoin saw over 30
billion dollars settled on chain pretty
impressive it was an all-time high still
though in the double-digit tens of
billions of dollars for on-chain
settlement the real exchange volume
right around eight billion dollars over
eight hundred thousand active addresses
and then the miners the miners
absolutely coming in with a monster
number miners have been paid 52 and a
half million dollars in the last 24
hours to secure the bitcoin network the
bitcoin network is the strongest most
decentralized computer network in the
world and the reason why so many people
are putting their computing power on the
bitcoin network to secure it to validate
transactions and to ensure the stable
sustainable resilient network is because
there's a 52 million dollar daily reward
right now for anyone who's doing that
pretty incredible when we then go and we
look at bitcoin compared to the s p and
gold we can see that bitcoin is now up
over 400 percent in the last year it's
up over 8 900 percent in the last five
years and it is up over 1.4 million
percent over the last 10 years now when
you compare bitcoin's 400 percent
increase to gold gold is down 9 on a
nominal basis which means that gold is
actually down on a real return basis 14
bitcoin up over 400 percent gold down 14
and when you look at the real return
basis and so bitcoin has absolutely
taken the place of gold as an inflation
hedge asset and institutional and retail
investors have dumped gold over the last
12 months even though the macro
environment called for interest rate
manipulation down and also historic
level of quantitative easing when we
look at the s p 500 a 25 gained more
than 2x the national average or the
historic average i'm sorry 25 being 2x
what normally would occur but
still dwarfed in comparison to bitcoin
at over 400 percent when we look at the
bitcoin price and the closing history
this is one of the most interesting
things right now is that bitcoin's price
has only been higher than 57 500 29 days
of its entire existence which is 0.62
percent of its entire life since january
3rd 2009 and so if you bought bitcoin
99.38
of bitcoin's life and you held it till
today your purchasing power has
appreciated compared to other assets
where the purchasing power of the
currencies where the purchasing power
decreases bitcoin's purchasing power has
increased over the last 12 years or so
and so 99.38
i don't do public math but i think
that's right over the time bitcoin's
purchasing power has increased when we
look at the bitcoin verse other assets
like gold s p 500 nasdaq or treasuries
we also can see that the roi again 400
percent you can see things like tlt is
down 11.6 which is pretty crazy the
compound annual growth rate of bitcoin
today comes in over the last 10 years at
161
161 percent compounded annually for a
decade absolute monster numbers and then
if you look at the sharpe ratios over
one in five years bitcoin denomina or
dominating the rest of the financial
markets absolutely destroying anything
else bitcoin has proven to become that
apex predator of financial markets but
bitcoin is not only a financial asset
something that you buy and hope for
financial performance michael saylor
over the weekend had a great tweet that
really explained and highlighted the
value of bitcoin he said bitcoin is
superior due to engineering not
tribalism the protocol is better suited
to organic growth of a decentralized
network with integrity and security
across political jurisdictions the
stability of the base layer drives
faster innovation in the application
layers above and so bitcoin is not just
an asset that you can buy and hold a
global store of value something that is
censorship resistant but it is also a
payment rail and a decentralized
platform of which applications will be
built on top of it we've seen everything
from the lightning network to other
applications but what michael is
specifically talking about here is the
engineering superiority the ability for
it to be suited for organic growth a
decentralized network with integrity and
security across any jurisdiction it
solely exists in cyberspace in the
virtual economy somewhere that is not
tied to a physical jurisdiction and the
stability of the base layer drives that
faster innovation of anything that is
built on top of it now it is of course
well understood that people in the
retail market people in the financial
market and also folks who have been
building in and around the bitcoin and
crypto industry understand this asset
they understand how it works and they
understand what the financial elements
of it are but one person that you
probably would not expect to really
understand it is politicians and what we
saw last week at the texas blockchain
summit was ted cruz standing on stage or
sitting on stage giving a talk about
bitcoin and he had very articulate take
nick carter went ahead and transcribed
the entire uh talk but what i wanted to
do is i want to call it a very specific
part at one point ted cruz said it's a
weird point a lot of the discussion
around bitcoin views bitcoin as a
consumer of energy a lot of the
criticism directed at it is the
consumption of energy the perspective
i'm suggesting is very much the reverse
which is a way to strengthen our energy
infrastructure and it also has one of
the most exciting things about crypto is
the ability to unlock stranded
renewables so there are a lot of places
on earth where the sun shines a lot and
the wind blows a lot but there aren't
any power lines and so it's not
economically feasible to use that energy
and the beauty of bitcoin mining is that
if you can connect to the internet you
can use that energy and derive value
from those renewables in a way that
would be impossible otherwise and i
think we're gonna see in the next five
years massive innovations in that regard
as well it is incredible to see a
sitting politician articulate bitcoin
bitcoin mining and it's interfacing with
the energy grid in such a great way he
obviously understands the value of
bitcoin mining and he sees how bitcoin
is not simply a high consumer of
electricity but rather bitcoin can serve
as a great catalyst for growth
investment and build out of energy
infrastructure and so whether you're
looking at bitcoin as a financial asset
whether you're looking at it as an
engineering feat or whether you are
looking at it as its positive impact on
the energy grid or other parts of our
non-bitcoin lives what you start to
understand is we are watching an asset
grow from the corners of the internet
into the mainstream to be repriced by
markets and to capture the imagination
of the entire world
that is what bitcoin is doing right
before us and people are looking and
saying hey it went up a little bit it
went down a little bit but they're
losing the bigger picture bitcoin has
now reached the mainstream and we are
likely to continue to see a drastic
increase in the adoption of the asset
not only from individual investors not
only from institutions like financial
institutions and corporations and not
only from nation states like el salvador
and maybe brazil and others but bitcoin
is also becoming an asset that is
penetrating every industry on earth
we're seeing the oil and gas the
capitalism of america start to embrace
this and i don't think it's going to
stop anytime soon when we look at the
totality of what's happening right now
is there ever been a more exciting time
to be involved in bitcoin no i was just
i was thinking why you were talking like
one of the craziest things i thought i
saw on that chart was uh just the
performance of bitcoin relative to other
assets right and when you look at it
compared to gold and the s p the s p the
gold's down so we'll just kind of knock
that out of the way immediately but but
the s p is up 25 this year that that
would be an incredible incredible
incredible year right when you when you
think about in history uh 10 would be
great right 12 would be fantastic 25 is
incredible uh kind of in the face of
pandemic and everything that's going on
so i think when you look at bitcoin has
outperformed it drastically it's up 400
this year that's an incredible rate of
return relative to other assets and
people say oh it's volatile you could
invest the wrong time you could lose
your money etc we're near all-time highs
again and then you can just dunk on them
with volatility ratios right so when you
look at the sharpe ratio bitcoin's
outperformed there any kind of uh
performance measure that you indicate
with bitcoin it's outperformed
traditional asset classes so i think
that's one important thing and then yeah
to your point like we talk about this
all the time the shift from traditional
analog assets to digital assets is going
to be one of the largest uh and greatest
wealth creation opportunities of our
lifetime right and i think people are
underestimating it still really really
right so when you look at 2017-2018 and
the bull run that we experienced there
we're three years four years from now
right we had an opportunity everyone had
the opportunity it was on the news all
day it was talked about on twitter
everyone was talking about it you had an
opportunity to go do your homework and
learn about it right and now those
people are benefiting from the
appreciation and price back to near
all-time highs and hopefully much more
through that john what do you think
we've already had an exciting start to
q4 i can see it continuing on this
trajectory right new institutions bring
big money into the space retail buyers
keep on buying um etf approval that is
looming around we have uh we are setting
up for an exciting thing that was an
interesting step though 29 days is the
only time you would be down if you
bought on 29 trading days over
a 12-year period that is insane yeah and
just to be clear that ha that is uh true
of a lot of assets that are all hitting
all-time highs consistently
yes on snp nasdaq all of them but the
point being that uh folks like to point
at the volatility and the constant just
up and down and they say oh this super
volatile asset how do i possibly put in
a portfolio but what we're starting to
realize is over long periods of time
it's one of the best if not the single
best way to protect your purchasing
power and and potentially increase your
purchasing power uh as well on top of
that what becomes really interesting is
when you start to understand that as
adoption comes in it has a positive
feedback loop for bitcoin so ultimately
bitcoin is one of the only assets in the
world that as the price goes higher
more people become interested in it
right if you think of a stock as the
price of a stock goes higher a lot of
times people say oh it's overvalued oh i
can't see it going much higher oh i
couldn't see it going double here but
because bitcoin went from zero it was
zero on january 3rd 2009 to now a
trillion dollars it's just now entering
kind of the sweet spot if you think of
like a baseball hitter right they take
pitch take pitch take pitch ball ball
ball now here comes a fast ball right
down the middle because now that we
enter into a trillion dollar asset class
between a trillion and 20 trillion every
institutional investor in the world can
start to take swings at it right now
they can start to allocate now they can
start to invest they don't have to uh
hide behind the claim that bitcoin's too
small it's not yet worth our time to dig
into it it's not yet big enough for us
to actually allocate tens of billions of
dollars to it once it crossed over a
trillion game on and i think that's
where you're going to see a lot of
really large institutions start to
allocate to the asset which again is a
positive feedback loop because then if
you have more people allocating your fix
apply asset price goes up as price goes
up more people become interested and
it's in this really really interesting
um kind of uh um appreciation or
repricing of the world everyone's trying
to figure out what the hell
is a decentralized digital global store
of value worth and if you tell me it's
worth a trillion dollars i disagree i
think it's worth something that is
multiples higher how long does it take
to get there what do we need to happen
to get there that's all up for debate
but i think most people look at this and
say if i show you a decentralized
digital store of value that's censorship
resistant that's resilient and it's
backed by the strongest computer network
in the world what's that worth if you
think it's worth less than some
individual companies you're crazy it
might be it's worth a hell of a lot more
than gold i'll tell you that right and
we're what 15 to gold right so like i
would refer to that as almost the
baseline of where i think we can get to
right and then and then there's a lot
more on top of that that we could see
but yeah relative to gold and other
assets like that i don't even think it's
a question of like kind of overtaking it
it's just a matter of how long does it
take what has to happen to get us there
completely agree we've hit a thousand
likes which we're gonna give away
another 250 of bitcoin right here right
now what i want is what is your price
target for bitcoin by the end of the
year leave it in the chat what's your
price target for bitcoin by the end of
the year we're gonna pick one person
joe's in charge of picking the winner
right now give out 250
this is the way the show works it's free
you come here the entry fee is you smash
the like button every time we cross over
500 likes today 500 1 000 1500 2000 2500
etc we're going to give out 250 of
bitcoin for free
nowhere else in the world do you get to
come
learn laugh and earn that's the deal
that we have with you guys have you been
practicing that's pretty good
this morning
you were saying that in your sleep last
night was often don't pick a winner pick
a winner
all right uh
vince
carango is is that vince our brother in
there is vince sneaking in there no jin
said you guys doing giveaways
uh send us your twitter handle and you
congratulations vince congrats vince
appreciate you watching
and the good news is if we get 200 more
likes everyone will have another chance
facts facts all day long
bitcoin all day long we're giving out
free bitcoin all you got to do is you
got to smash the like button and we'll
get you by the way my favorite thing
about the entire show my favorite thing
is that when we give out bitcoin or an
eight-sleep mattress or jordans or nfl
tickets or whatever other crazy thing we
come up with maybe a car one day then
everyone congratulates the winner that's
my favorite part everyone's like hey
great job great job great job we're all
in this together that's what it's all
about that is great so come here you
learn you laugh and you earn joe came up
with that i just repeated it no problem
everyone's gonna have a chance we're
gonna be doing plenty of giveaways so
congrats to the winner and and everyone
keep watching and tuning into the next
one keep smashing the like button when
crossover 1500 will give you more wait
so i got a question for you do you think
we're anywhere close so like some people
that have gotten into bitcoin post 2017
bull run right and haven't necessarily
experienced maybe a little earlier this
year but like not on the full scale that
we saw previously are we even close to
the fomo amount that we're gonna see
towards the end of this thing no explain
what it is for some people too in 2017
bitcoin went from a thousand dollars to
twenty thousand dollars but what people
forget is that bitcoin went from ten
thousand dollars to twenty thousand
dollars in about 18 days at the end of
the year pretty much from the
mid-november uh until mid-december
somewhere in there it was 18 days went
from 10 000 to 20 000. now the way that
it worked was we actually went from 15
000 to 20 000 it only hung out at 20 000
for like three days it was like 72 hours
or so and then we kind of started to
come back down so a blow off top does
not mean that it went to 20 000 and hung
out there for months and then all of a
sudden it dropped 80 percent it
literally was the absolute top of so
many people fomoing in and trying to buy
it and so right now it's actually not
really any fomo at all which is pretty
crazy if you're in the bitcoin community
you feel like oh my god like like
bitcoin's moving bitcoin's not even at
an all-time high yet the press isn't
really paying attention the way that
they do when we start to hit all-time
highs and fomo kicks in institutions
aren't talking about it the way that
they are but once we cross over into a
new all-time high and you start the
second leg of a bull market in terms of
like moving towards a blow off top what
will likely occur is three things is how
i identify one you'll literally feel
like you can't go to sleep like you just
feel like oh my god like this is moving
so fast i have to keep paying attention
it's not healthy but you'll feel that
the second thing you're gonna see is
that you will see absolute capitulation
from institutions and from the media
they'll just go all in on talking about
it they can't stop because the feedback
loop they're getting is every time they
even mention the word bitcoin they're
gonna get so much engagement that the
incentives take over and they just start
to literally become like bitcoin
publications we saw it in 2017 we're
going to see it again at the end of this
year and so institutions now are going
to do the same thing you're going to see
athletes musicians teams
brands everyone gets on the train
because they realize that's where the
engagement on the internet is and that's
what drives uh content on the internet
is where is the engagement so you're
gonna get that uh that feeling where you
can't go to sleep you're gonna get the
feeling that every single person
everywhere you turn on the internet is
talking about it uh and then the last
thing is in your daily life the people
that you interact with that you may not
think about but that you interact with
on a daily basis taxi drivers barbers
your friend's cousin uh somebody that
you meet as you go for a walk at the
park uh you go to your kids baseball
game and there's another dad or a mom
sitting there in those everyday
conversations bitcoin will start coming
up and you'll literally say to yourself
why is my barber talking to me about
bitcoin why is the taxi driver talking
to me about bitcoin why is my kid's
friend's mom talking about bitcoin at
the baseball game that's when you can
start to feel that it has penetrated
outside of the bitcoin community and
we've gone back into kind of that
everyday retail uh conversation that's
when you know that we're getting near
one of these blow off tops now again
that doesn't mean that you should change
anything you're doing or do something
differently what it means though is you
need to be aware of what's actually
happening one of the best investment
principles is to control your emotions
whether it is in good times or bad times
a lot of people think about emotional
control in bad times the price of an
asset you hold has gone down
significantly and so when it goes down
you don't want to panic sell well the
exact same thing happens in good times
as well you don't want to become overly
exuberant around an asset just because
it continues to go up in price it's hard
to do it but i tend to think that having
emotional control in good and bad times
is one of the most important investing
skills so in that blow off top you'll
know it and it'll be unlike anything
you've ever been or felt before or been
involved in before if you're around in
2017 you could take what you experienced
then and my guess is just going to be
that on steroids now because there's
more people involved there's more
companies there's more media and the
moves are more aggressive too right it's
not going to be growing up dollars or a
thousand dollars gonna be going up five
thousand dollars for ten thousand
dollars if it goes up ten percent right
now it would be going up five thousand
five hundred dollars at a time right and
then once you breach a 100 grand now all
of a sudden a 10 movement is 10k and
again we'll see what happens but it
would not surprise me if we see multiple
times between now and the end of the
year 10 000
candles which means that bitcoin's price
will move 10 000 in a single day now
again that could be up or down right if
bitcoin was to draw down right now from
55 000 down 10k that would be about a 20
move right but it also is going to
happen on the way up as well a 10 move
in bitcoin is not really that crazy and
so when we start to get to the point
where ten percent is 10k candles it's
not going to be surprising i think to
see that happen multiple times can we
get a clap real quick our boy did a lot
of public math there i'm happy that was
good right that's pretty good i don't
think any retail investors are going to
move the needle and move bitcoin right
it's going to be all the institutions
that flow in with large capital to
contribute to the market we'll see i
just remember in 2017 kind of when we
were watching and everyone had been
interested in it kind of for a time
period uh before that and prior to that
so we had some kind of a baseline of
what the reaction would be in the
markets and social media and kind of
people you talk to on a regular basis it
was wild when it started rising there
was literally you couldn't turn on a tv
or a news station or go to a business
website cnbc blueberry all these places
you couldn't talk to friends you
couldn't go all these places without
having someone talk about it or ask
about it you were sitting in restaurants
people were talking about it nearby you
your barber was asking about it taxi
drivers were asking about all these
people wanted to talk about was bitcoin
i don't think we're anywhere close to
that yet and like you said when the
price starts to move much more
aggressively and they're bigger moves
with ten thousand dollar moves five
thousand dollars whatever it ends up
being uh 10 moves it's gonna be talked
about way way way more because people
just naturally uh psychologically think
that those are massive moves right even
though it's only ten percent a ten
thousand dollar move uh in a matter of
minutes or hours is a lot obviously and
i think it'll get people to talk about
it even more aggressively 1 500 likes
let's go we are gonna give out bitcoin
all day long today because you guys keep
pressing the like button what i want is
in the chat leave your twitter handle
all you have to do is type in your
twitter handle right now john's going to
pick one person who's going to win 250
worth of bitcoin on the spot live on the
show right now
you cross over 1.5 k likes we give out
250 of bitcoin that's how this works
leave your twitter account vince carango
wants to know he doesn't have a twitter
he went the previous winner he said can
i just email you my wallet address
uh vince uh leave your uh email address
maybe and then we will uh then we'll hit
you up we'll hit you up but leave your
email address so we can email you don't
be spamming him all right he's a winner
all right john who you got for us from
uh from the twitter winner 250 of
bitcoin for free getting handed out to
someone right now no pressure on john
please all right
alan
jacobson
allen jacobson come on
how do you spell it
a-l-a-n
space
j-a-c-o-b-s-o-n all right you got the
twitter account already yep oh we're in
business right now
you like that one huh john likes the
fact that everyone just left the twitter
account so you didn't have to go track
congrats to the winner congrats to the
winner allen jacobson congratulations
250 that's 750 bucks let's go follow me
on twitter so i can dm you smash the
like button so that when we get to 2000
we'll give out another 250 bucks a
bitcoin all right el salvador over the
weekend the president of el salvador
came out and he dropped uh just a banger
of a promo video for a brand new
veterinarian hospital and he explicitly
stated that they were going to use the
profits from bitcoin to build this
animal hospital now he clarified later
on but before we get to the
clarification he explicitly just tweeted
something simple he said we'll start
building the pet this pet hospital with
our bitcoin profits pretty simple in the
video absolute banger we're not going to
play because we don't want to get a
strike on youtube thanks susan but then
he went on to clarify i said by the way
we're not selling any bitcoin we're
using the us dollar part of the trust
since the bitcoin part is now worth more
than when the trust was established he
then said by the way the pet hospital
will probably appreciate in relation to
u.s dollars bitcoin on the contrary is a
deflationary currency so he obviously
was completely
trolling here but he's serious about
building this veterinary hospital so
what they did was they went ahead they
put 150 u.s dollars in a fund that fund
bought some bitcoin i believe they
bought around 30 million dollars of
bitcoin so far that 30 million dollars
of bitcoin has appreciated rapidly some
of the salvadorians who got bitcoin as
part of downloading the chivo wallet are
up nearly 40 percent
in the last three or four weeks so
obviously bitcoin's price has
appreciated aggressively since el
salvador started to buy bitcoin now what
they are gonna do is rather than sell
bitcoin to get the profits and then use
that to build this hospital instead
they're going to take u.s dollars that
were previously earmarked to buy bitcoin
they're going to take some of that and
go and build the hospital so quite
literally bitcoin is helping to fund the
creation and build out of this pet
hospital now you can make all sorts of
critiques around the idea should they
actually be building a pet hospital
should they be building something else
should they be helping with some other
sort of social program should they maybe
be investing in other types of
infrastructure i'm not an expert on
salvadorian politics i'm not an expert
on the gdp nor the national budget nor
around their national goals but what i
do know is that we are watching a
country on board into an asset that has
appreciated aggressively so far since
they started and they are now able to
redirect part of a budget that was
earmarked for bitcoin instead to do
something else and so that is the value
of an asset that protects and
appreciates your purchasing power and if
you go back to the last two tweets that
he had where he said that they're not
selling any of the bitcoin but and
because the bitcoin part is now worth
more that makes sense they bought
bitcoin and bitcoin's price went up but
he also went on to say that the pet
hospital will probably appreciate in
relation to u.s dollars and bitcoin on
the contrary is a deflationary currency
so what he's talking about is by
literally buying land by building a
physical building the us dollar value is
going to continue to depreciate that's
why real estate investors in the united
states do so well is because the
currency devalues against their hard
asset and so he is explicitly stating
how an investor thinks and why as a fiat
currency denomination owning real assets
ends up being such a great financial
decision so what do we think about the
idea of them actually going in taking
money from the fund that was earmarked
to buy more bitcoin and instead building
the pet hospital i think it's good i
think it's cool right like i think uh
people were surprised at first because
the way he ordered his first tweet was
that they were selling bitcoin to go and
funded and i think that shocked some
people uh but with his clarification i
think it's good i think he's showing
that uh one of the incredible things is
right when you look at el salvador they
have i think six million people or so
that live there and three million of
them already have bitcoin wallets it was
put in place just a little over a month
ago bitcoin has appreciated rapidly
right more people there now have bitcoin
wallets than traditional bank accounts
and for the first time in their life
they're watching a currency that they
own and are invested in appreciate in
value right and i think it's incredible
and i think that anyone uh that is
hoping or rooting for this project to
fail is wrong and they are doing a great
disservice right to these people uh and
i think that we should all be rooting
for this to succeed and i think that
this is kind of one of those things that
uh is ancillary to kind of the main goal
or the main project but it's a good
outcome and it's and it's a benefit and
something that we should also be talking
about
putting this in the hands of every or
half you would say the country's popular
population is amazing for those
individuals not only because it
appreciates in value but it also gets
them interested in the idea that
something they own can actually go up in
value over time rather than just
consuming goods uh so on that note it's
amazing they're up what 40 in 21 days
something like that um that's awesome i
i think it uh it's yeah i agree john but
i think it's it's difficult to uh a lot
of people have have a trouble stepping
outside of kind of their traditional in
their daily life right like we live here
in the us we live in miami and we're
blessed in a lot of ways and fortunate
in a lot of ways that we have the
ability to protect our wealth there's
inflation sure but purchasing power
doesn't diminish overnight to
astronomical levels we're kind of in a
very very very good economic situation
in other countries like el salvador it's
not like that right people were
incentivized to go pick up the 30 worth
of bitcoin uh by downloading and getting
a wallet because of how much that
economic incentive meant to them right
so 30 means a lot and that was a good
incentive and it worked obviously half
the country has it but i think that the
idea that some people uh whether it's i
don't know if it's traditional media but
there's certainly individuals online
that are rooting for this project to
fail in some sense or don't think it
will succeed or would would be happy to
see it not succeed i think is wrong and
it's kind of disgusting to be honest
it's like we want these people to be in
a better economic situation i think
bitcoin provides that the people
cheering against this are losers
even better said like i mean like how do
you cheer against a country improving
their citizens uh situation again you
can disagree with how they do it you can
disagree with why they're doing it you
can disagree with who's doing it you can
disagree with the asset they're using
you can disagree with all of the
execution but if you're actively
cheering against a population to be able
to one succeed and two increase their
financial situation you're a loser
that's what you are you're a loser and
by the way i hope that most people are
actually conflating cheering for the
success of the population with oh i
don't like the way they're doing i don't
like who's doing i don't like the asset
et cetera again you can debate the
execution but we should all buy into the
idea that anyone in the world regardless
of what country they live in what
language they speak what their religion
is what color their skin is what their
wealth is what the education level is
who their parents are where they come
from
we should want them to live a better
life than they live today and if you're
the richest person in the world we
should be cheering for you to become
better if you're the poorest person in
the world we should be cheering for you
to become better and everyone in between
we should be cheering for humanity to be
pushed forward we currently today live
in the most prosperous safest time in
human history if you go all the way back
thousands and thousands of years we live
in the safest most prosperous time in
human history but that doesn't mean we
get to rest on our laws that doesn't
mean we can be complacent we should be
cheering for everyone to continue to
progress forward and to get into a
better situation and that includes the
people in el salvador and so whether you
like who's doing it how they're doing it
what assets they're using etc i
personally am cheering for the 6.5
million people who live in that country
to be better off tomorrow than they are
today and that's what i think ultimately
everyone should do and if you happen to
be in a situation where you're not
cheering for them to be in a better uh
position then maybe you should be asking
yourself why and if you'd like to talk
about it we're always here you can tune
in every day from 11 to 1 and we'll talk
about it and we'll try to help you
understand why you should be cheering
for humanity that's all now before we
move on to the next topic we're real
close to 2k should we let's make a big
push i'm going to count to three on the
count of three you hit the like button
we cross over 2k we'll give out another
250 worth of bitcoin one two three press
the like button joe what are we gonna
have people do in order to pick who the
next person is to win 250 dollars for
free just for coming here to learn laugh
and earn
you guys yeah
you guys like that right learn laugh and
earn i mean i'm not saying that i'm a
genius but i'm saying i came up with
that off the dome and that might be the
uh the new tactic you have to clarify
that a lot i'm not saying i'm a genius
but
all right uh i want everyone to i got it
ready i want everyone to comment in the
chat
who introduced you to bitcoin or how you
heard about bitcoin the first time oh
that's good who introduced you to
bitcoin how'd you learn about bitcoin
we're gonna pick somebody right now live
on the show another 250
for free in bitcoin only place in the
world where you come to
learn
laugh
john was looking at me real crazy like i
didn't know what i was talking about no
i knew what you're trying to do all
right just making sure who you got joe
i can't pick someone that says you
know somebody who says me
um all right let's give them a second
we don't got a lot of people said
they're barber
[Laughter]
my barber told me about in 2017. i'm not
gonna lie when it was down my barber was
complaining his head off about it all
right i got mark puffinberger
i don't know what's up with the name but
i like it
uh he learned on silk road
why'd you pick him oh gee he's an
uh all right mark you post your twitter
account uh you win mark puffinberger i
mean you should just win for
an excellent name whether that's your
real one or not you win uh potions
post your twitter account and we'll go
ahead and get you 250 with a bitcoin
guess what if you didn't win no problem
we're going to get the 2.5 k likes
here's your friendly reminder you should
go right now go into your group chat go
on to an email list go on to social
media i don't care if you literally send
a carrier pigeon or a smoke signal go
tell your brother your sister your mom
your dad your aunt your uncle your
brother's boyfriend your sister's
girlfriend go tell your next-door
neighbor go tell the stranger at the
store tell your wife tell your side
chick tell your dog tell your pet snake
whoever you have in your contact books
on social media in an email list go tell
them right now come watch the best
business show because on the best
business show you get to learn laugh and
earn which is going to be our new
tagline only because every time i say it
john smirks and that means that's a
winner because anything you say you're
just like that's the greatest tackle i
never we're rolling with it your
sister's girlfriend your side chick i
think you said at one point and your pet
snake
yeah now you got people in the comments
saying i'm gonna tell my wife's
boyfriend
not going there all right let's keep
going
uh the united states has approved the uh
the sec has approved the volt crypto
industry revolution and tech etf which
is one a mouthful but two his goal is to
provide investors with exposure to
publicly traded companies with exposure
to bitcoin so obviously the bitcoin etf
has not yet been approved so the next
best thing according to the volt
crypto industry revolution and tech etf
is to buy the equity of companies that
have bitcoin exposure now if you want to
get bitcoin exposure it the first
question i have is why they called it
the volt crypto industry uh revolution
and tech etf and not the volt bitcoin
industry revolution and tech etf maybe
regulators wouldn't allow them or
there's some other reason but that's one
question that is unanswered now the fund
is the fifth etf that the san
francisco-based investment advisor has
launched and the fund which will not
hold any crypto assets directly will be
listed on the new york stock exchange at
least 80 percent of the fund's net
assets are going to be invested in quote
unquote crypto stocks those are stocks
that have some exposure to bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies the remaining 20 will
be invested in more traditional stocks
to offset the risk of the funds focused
portfolio now when you start to think
about this if you're going to create an
etf and you're going to tell everyone
that you're going to give them exposure
to actually
publicly traded companies that have that
other exposure to bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies you're essentially
saying hey give me your money and then
i'm going to get you indirect exposure
to these assets
but if you only put 80 percent of the
money into those companies and the other
20 just go in traditional stocks it kind
of defeats the purpose of what you're
trying to accomplish now companies that
are potentially going to be included in
the etf are things like microstrategy
marathon bit farms etc and what everyone
has their eyes on is the actual bitcoin
etf so this feels like kind of a
watered-down version of what folks are
trying to get to so if we can't actually
get the bitcoin etf instead now we have
this idea of a traditional etf that
holds stocks that then hold the asset so
it's indirect exposure underlying it but
if we're going to approve these
it's about time we approve the bitcoin
etf now the bitcoin etf has two
different ways to do it you can have one
based on futures or you can have one
based on actual bitcoin and what
ultimately now seems to be the rumor is
that the real bitcoin kind of in air
quotes etf is not the one that is likely
to get approved but instead of futures
based etf is the one that is likely to
get approved there are all sorts of cost
and all sorts of slippage etc concerns
with the future based etf around bitcoin
compared to the real bitcoin etf but we
have to be patient we have to wait to
see what actually happens no one knows
there's over a dozen pending
applications
for bitcoin etfs everyone from skybridge
to arc to fidelity to galaxy digital
block five global x and a number of
others uh i believe that we also have
gray scales in there i believe bitwise
etc some of these folks have put them
forward some of them have taken them out
some of them have resubmitted so that
there's kind of a constant revolving
door of people trying to get the
approval i do not believe that we will
see just one single bitcoin etf provider
approved where essentially regulators
become a king maker they say hey this is
the winner instead what i think is
likely to happen is that the regulators
are going to say okay it is time it is
now time they had us in the first half
but in the fourth quarter it is time we
are going to approve a bitcoin etf and
they may say that they're gonna do it
through real bitcoin or through a
futures based product they choose the
futures based product what they're
likely to do is select two three four
five different etf applications approved
them all and allowed the market to
decide where the assets will flow that
competition for assets flowing into a
bitcoin etf is going to come down to a
lot of different things some of it is
going to be around the custody there may
be institutions that worry about a
specific custody provider or more
attracted to another custody provider
there's going to be things like fees if
one charges two and a half or three
percent on the fund and somebody else
charges one you obviously get a better
financial performance from a fee
standpoint and then lastly is what i
call familiarity right what is the thing
that gives you peace of mind there are
certain brands that have filed for a
bitcoin etf that everyone knows their
household names among institutional
investors and so they probably feel more
comfortable allocating to those funds
compared to a startup or some sort of
brand new entrant to the market i can
argue and so do many others that that's
not fair or that isn't necessarily the
best investment strategy but i think
that will absolutely play into the
institutional investors decision as to
where they put their dollars when it
comes to a bitcoin etf now i also think
that we not only are going to see brand
new funds get the approval and start the
bitcoin etf we know that there's a
number of bitcoin etfs that have been
approved in canada and other markets uh
and then on top of that we've also seen
things like the bitcoin trust or other
crypto asset trusts from bitwise etc
that are on u.s exchanges and so when
you start to look at what's already in
the market even though there are no
bitcoin etfs available in the united
states markets you could quickly see
people taking the ones in canada trying
to cross-list them into the u.s and you
could also see the current asset
managers that have traded trust in the
united states converting them to etf
structures that provide the redemptions
and other things that etfs provide and
so ultimately i think a bitcoin etf
approval is likely folks like those over
at bloomberg eric and the team they have
about 75 confidence i've seen them
publicly talking about that a bitcoin
etf will be approved before the end of
the year we'll see but i do think that
it's likely to come i think that we will
not only see brand new funds get
approved and started and have multiple
of them so there's true competition and
a free market will settle where the
assets flow but i also think you're
going to see the conversion of the trust
into etfs over time and you'll also see
people from other jurisdictions like
canada and elsewhere try to cross list
into the u.s so once that approval
happens i think it is going to get
absolutely bananas you're going to see
assets flow into these structures
because there's a ton of folks sitting
on the sidelines saying i want to get
the allocation i know that i need the
allocation but i can't do it in existing
structures i can't invest in a private
fund i don't want to invest in the trust
cause there's no redemptions etc those
people they've got a lot of money and
when this etf gets approved there is
going to be massive asset flows into
these assets in my opinion right john
this is a step in the right direction um
it's a little unfortunate to see that
they delayed the actual bitcoin etfs
till late november at the earliest um
simply just kicking the cane down the
road i view this volt etf as someone who
has set up a structure basically to get
management fees on it like any
traditional etf like the s p 500 if you
wanted to break it down and actually
invest in those companies um you could
and not pay that management fee but it's
really a big hassle to do it most of
these companies either have bitcoin on
their balance sheet um are in bitcoin
related space i don't like the idea that
it's
labeled as a bitcoin etf in the sense of
only 80 will be involved in
cryptocurrencies and 20 more traditional
assets so that's a little different but
um
i don't know we'll see how much money
actually flows into it i think it's
interesting because like
as a retail investor most retail
investors if not all of them just
traditionally buy uh bitcoin directly
right they get exposure to the asset
directly by buying bitcoin itself
institutional investors are different
right for a bunch of regulatory reasons
and complications uh they like to
diversify and buy the etf or the other
uh kind of ability to get exposure to
the asset traditionally that's been
grayscale's trust right which has
essentially held the monopoly on the
institutional market and the
institutional capital flowing into the
space that for a long time created a
massive premium in the space that has
come down to a discount over the last
few months but traditionally over the
last few years that had created a
premium on the price but now as these
other kind of vehicles get approved for
them to get exposure into bitcoin
whether it's you know public equities
that own bitcoin or have exposure to
bitcoin or an eventual etf that uh gives
them direct exposure to bitcoin itself
these are all good things right this is
going to push the price up on the demand
side we already know the supply side
that's situated uh it's constrained we
know exactly how much is going to come
out it's programmatic et cetera so all
we're really looking at is the demand
side and the etfs are very very very
important because the institutional
capital is where we're going to see
massive inflows on the demand side and
this is where the price can really
appreciate so i think whether it's kind
of a step in the right direction where
we end up actually getting that etf
approved within the next six eight ten
months uh is very important and i think
from a retail investor's perspective
this is something that people should
watch because it's gonna make the price
appreciate on bitcoin much more rapidly
than it would on kind of just retail
investors continue to adopt it and
continue to get while it's continuing to
be brought into the network
john when you think about a bitcoin etf
do you think that would change any of
your friends uh appetite for buying
bitcoin or the ones that are interested
they've already went and bought bitcoin
on one of the exchanges yeah i mean most
people that have probably already been
interested in bitcoin um or at least
already bought it they're not going
after these etfs i think they're not
really waiting that's more on the
institutional side but uh i mean look i
i went and bought bitcoin i didn't wait
for the atf approval i i kind of had a
feeling that it was going to appreciate
a lot before the etf approval and a lot
after but um no i think a lot of them if
you're already interested in
cryptocurrencies you most likely already
probably own it on one of the big
exchanges on a cold storage wallet or
all the other various ways you can store
it um but i think for the institutions
it's going to be massive to see all that
all that capital flow in
we're real close to 2.5 k likes we're
gonna give out another 250 of bitcoin
for free to one person who came here on
the count of three hit the like button
one two three hit the like button when
we crossed 2.5 k likes we're gonna pick
one person they're gonna get 250 of
bitcoin for free
on friday late
there was breaking news that the white
house was considering an executive order
to drive more scrutiny and understanding
of the crypto industry specifically the
biden administration was considering
that executive order for federal
agencies which would require them to
study the crypto industry and provide
recommendations on their oversight so
this would be an executive order that
would drive specific federal
organizations to actually take a deeper
look to be more thoughtful to actually
go and talk to the players in the
industry to evaluate the market
structure and to come up with a
recommendation for that oversight the
order would generally ask agencies to
study various aspects of the industry
and it would try to clarify the
responsibilities that different agencies
have around crypto many of the agencies
that are included would include the
treasury department the commerce
department the national science
foundation and the national security
agencies now when this came out i think
that there was a whole bunch of
misinformation and also a belief that
people should just stick the middle
finger up to the politicians i put out a
tweet thread that i want to go through
that explicitly talks about the nuance
that's involved here so first i said
listen if you want to retweet this and
tell the politicians that they should
fix the fiat system before they try to
screw up the crypto system and that
tweet went viral as you would expect now
the reason is because that's the
underlying sentiment in people in the
industry is that they are trying to
figure out why would people who can't
actually keep the fiat system from being
screwed up try to now come into this new
digital financial system but that's not
the whole story if we go to the next
tweet it says that in many cases the
bitcoin and crypto industry has more
regulation than the legacy system it is
not an unregulated industry if i spend
fiat i pay sales tax if i spend bitcoin
i pay sales tax end capital gains tax
bitcoin as a currency is over regulated
compared to other currencies in the
market in new york city the financial
capital of the world you need more
licenses to start a crypto company than
a legacy fintech organization that is
not good or bad that's just what it is
it is more regulation to start that
business in new york city compared to
others the next tweet says many of the
largest companies in the crypto industry
are regulated by 50 plus regulators
organizations and governing bodies that
is a lot it's expensive it's time
consuming they're doing the best that
they can there's also a strong argument
that we don't need more regulation and
oversight but rather we need more
efficient and clearer oversight it isn't
a thing where we should go create more
oversight more regular regulatory bodies
and create more rules maybe what is
actually needed is to be more efficient
with it what exactly are the rules make
sure that those are clear and make sure
people abide by them by be creating more
efficiency and more clarity that
ultimately may solve the problem rather
than simply just piling on more
regulation then i went on to explain
that one of the big difficulties is that
many of the politicians who are
advocating for more regulation they
can't describe what a blockchain is how
it works what differentiates various
assets and why these are essential for
american economic prosperity in the
future obviously there's a lot of issues
if the people who are trying to create
the rules or who are trying to oversee
the overseers if they don't actually
understand the technology now we talked
earlier about senator ted cruz we also
know that senator lumus or congressman
warren davidson they have a very very
good handle on this stuff and so
hopefully they can educate their peers
and their colleagues so that we can get
more educated folks actually
participating here then i went on to say
it is obvious that the legacy system is
not working for tens of millions of
americans we have over five percent
unemployment we have eleven million open
jobs right now there's over five percent
inflation the wealth gap is wider than
ever before and the new system offers
hope that we can design something better
something more inclusive and something
that works now if we're serious about
building a system that is durable
scalable and effective then we need to
participate uh participation from all
parties politicians can't do it alone it
is arrogant and ignorant of them to
think that but the bitcoin and crypto
community can't do it alone either and
this was my main point is that it's easy
to yell and scream at the politicians
and at the regulators and say you don't
understand you shouldn't do this alone
but the same thing can be said about our
industry as well we need everyone to
come together and do it together this
new digital financial system provides an
opportunity to drastically fix many of
our sins of the past we need the
technologists entrepreneurs investors
regulators politicians corporations and
individual citizens to work together all
hands on deck
every person in the market must
participate must pitch in the constant
labeling of the bitcoin or crypto crowd
as criminals and nefarious actors is
provably inaccurate we can show you that
that is true but the labeling of all
politicians is out of touch boomers is
wrong too
there are a lot of great people who
share the ultimate goal of achieving a
better system and together we can build
that america has an opportunity in front
of us we can embrace this new technology
we can encourage innovation we can
create trillions in economic value and
we can ensure that we remain the global
leader people just need to be willing to
work together to accomplish that and
then lastly i finished up and i said the
free market has determined that these
assets are valuable which is a very key
point the free market has assigned
trillions of dollars of value to these
assets hundreds of millions of people
around the world use these technology
products the government should work to
support the will of the people and i'm
optimistic that we'll end up in a good
place so people got really scared they
got really nervous when they heard that
there would be an executive order but
the executive order isn't anything that
is necessarily overreaching it is simply
that they want federal agencies to go
ahead and to study the assets study the
market study the players understand
better which federal organization should
be participating here and how but i
think that we as an industry must be
very very careful that they don't do it
alone we must participate the
entrepreneurs the investors
and other folks in the market should
and are spending time with these
politicians with these regulators trying
to educate them so that they can make
good decisions just like you or i if we
are uneducated about something we're
likely to make mistakes and so education
is the key in my opinion
yeah i i think uh it's it's naive to
think that the government wouldn't get
involved in some capacity right like
this is going to be uh hopefully
potentially a multi-trillion dollar
asset class within the next 75 days
really right so uh it's it's kind of
naive to think that the government
wouldn't look at that wouldn't look at
ways to
explore it regulate it interact with it
part of the executive order mentioned
innovation right so they're gonna look
at ways that they can help innovate in
the space i don't necessarily know if
the government should be involved in
that uh but at the end of the day i
think what's important is not
necessarily that they're gonna be
looking at it that's to be expected in
my opinion it's that they hire the right
people to look at it right and they hire
someone that knows what they're doing
within the crypto space if you're going
to uh go out and work with the legacy
people that are in the government
currently that had no experience in
crypto previously have never worked in
the industry haven't dealt with it on a
significant time basis and are used to
the traditional fiat system that we
operate in and analog assets i think
that is a mistake to put them in charge
of regulating an entire new industry
that they don't know anything about
necessarily right so they can go out and
they can learn but i think it'd be much
more uh it would be a much better
solution if president biden and all the
other people in government instead said
hey look let's go find people that know
what's going on here right we should use
this as an advantage other countries uh
like china are shutting it down and
saying it's not a good thing and we
shouldn't be using it and protecting
national security and all this stuff
like this is stuff that the u.s should
be taking advantage of right and i think
that the key will be uh who they put in
charge of it how they look at it how
they regulate it how they try to
innovate on it and stuff like that i
think it's too early to tell obviously
like the executive order hasn't even
replaced yet to the best of my knowledge
but i think it's mostly important that
they hire the right people to do it and
don't rely on kind of traditional people
within the government and the federal
reserve and places like that to regulate
this industry completely agree john any
last words the government is notorious
for
not wanting to change and acting slow on
things this to be honest should have
already been done they should have been
looking at it extensively uh even since
2016-17 i'm surprised it was probably on
their radar but they didn't take it
seriously as an asset uh this will only
help i think by having people go into it
the regulations one part i think the
education is a major part they need to
go get educated all of them do and then
this will also clear up kind of like
who's responsible for what in this
industry which i think will help this
sounds bad but i don't trust the
government to do anything with it i
don't trust them at all to do the right
thing when it comes to crypto we're
gonna see what happens that ultimately
we'll see what that's my opinion on it
yeah i hear it
all right we just crossed over 2.5 k
likes plan b is going to come on in a
minute but if we cross over 2.5 with k
likes that means we're going to give
away 250 worth of bitcoin what i want
you to do right now is i want you to in
the comments leave your your comment in
the chat that says who is somebody that
you taught about bitcoin
who is somebody you taught about bitcoin
it's good enough for you to learn about
bitcoin but who did you teach about it
who in your life was it your brother
your mom your sister your cousin's
uncle's dog
did you teach john what is it your
wife's father-in-law
[Laughter]
your wife's brother sister's friend
let's go all right here we go i'm gonna
pick one person i'm gonna pick one
person right now if you drop your
twitter handle that might help you get
picked too
let's see uh johnny's got a system here
well mark puffer puffington i think it
was somebody said you don't yeah if you
don't answer and put your email in the
chat we will re-pick the winner snooze
you lose all right i got the winner jay
caldwell you win he said my daughters
and my son just dropping bombs on his
kid teaching them about sound money i
love it
what
nothing dude
nothing
go ahead tell me no he's dropping bombs
you're right i just thought it was funny
i'm allowed to laugh at a joke you laugh
at your own jokes all the time so
congratulations
all right jay you win 50.
drop your twitter account and uh and
we'll get you the 250 with the bitcoin
uh we're going to go to commercial real
quick and when we come back plan b the
creator of the stock to flow model is
coming on i don't think that there is a
bearish bone
in plan b's body he's full bull full
bull full bowl my guy was dropping check
marks throughout the entire summer
models
model's working check when we come back
plan b will be with us go tell your
friend your mother your son
everyone plan b's coming on live make
sure you smash like button cross over
the next 500 likes we'll give away
another 250 for the bitcoin i'll be
right back
[Music]
wait don't skip this ad all in one
platform you can save spend earn borrow
and invest that's right sofi has a super
app you can buy stocks and etfs trade
crypto or open an automated portfolio
all with no account minimums and zero
commission on trades use the link below
or go to sofi.com
to sign up for a sofi active invest
account and you can win up to a thousand
dollars plus members now have access to
upcoming ipos before they begin trading
on an exchange which is really
especially cool for retail investors and
with sofi social investing you can
follow other members and see what
they're investing in including me
seriously to see how i'm investing just
search anthony pompliano in the sofi app
start investing today with sofi at
sofi.com thanks again to sophie for
sponsoring this episode
and make sure you go to sofi.com to sign
up today
[Music]
[Music]
all right we are back
with the man the myth and legend
plan b
plan b can you hear me
i can anthony john joe hi how are you
doing we're doing fantastic how are you
yeah very good very good i i bet you are
all right first i want to start with a
stock to flow model uh you're the
creator of this and most people point to
it as uh kind of the single guiding
light to them in terms of uh the
relationship of bitcoin's price to these
halving cycles so talk us through a
little bit about what the stock to flow
model is and then what it's showing us
so far
yeah so the stock to flow ratio is a
ratio from the commodities market
actually that that tells you something
about an assets scarcity
it divides the stock the reserves of a
certain assets uh by the flow the newly
issued
bitcoins or or gold newly mined gold and
if you divide the stock by the flow you
get the stock to flow ratio so that
ratio was known for ages in the
commodities market what i did was
connect that with the market value of uh
well bitcoin in the beginning but later
also the other assets
like silver
and diamonds and gold and real estate
and what you find that there is a
perfect linear relationship in the
logarithmic space so
that was quite shocking and and with
that you can you can actually predict
the price of bitcoin very roughly i
should say but you can do it
and uh because we know the stock to flow
ratio of uh of bitcoin it's
pre-programmed and that's yeah that's a
very nice thing
and it's of course very bullish
at the moment it predicts um
somewhere around a hundred thousand
dollar bitcoin for the current halving
cycle which is 2020 2024.
so we're actually heading towards that
yeah
it's that so when you think of the stock
to flow ratio one of the things that i'm
fascinated by is it comes from the
commodities market but it's actually
potentially more accurate when it comes
to bitcoin because we know with
certainty and can prove the supply of
both the outstanding supply and the
daily incoming supply describe a little
bit about why that certainty and that
that verifiability is so important to
the accuracy of a model like this
yeah so for example with gold we don't
know how much gold is mined every year
it's it's uh we can make a forecast
uh but we don't know it um precisely and
a lot of factors impact that that uh
supply that that mind supply of of gold
and one of the factors impacting that is
is price right if the price of gold is
high then the miners will will uh
increase their production and if the
price of gold is low they will decrease
the production and the mining of gold
with bitcoin
um
yeah well the whole production the whole
flow is pre-programmed every 10 minutes
on average right every 10 minutes
there's a block and in that block is a
block subsidy
um with the new bitcoins for the miner
that found the hash of that block so uh
we know sort of that every 10 minutes
and and for the whole year
uh how how much bitcoins will be mined
of course we don't know it exactly
because there is some um
variability in the in the 10-minute
interval sometimes it it lasts an hour
sometimes you have like three blocks in
10 minutes but on average we know and
especially long-term we know what the
stock to flow ratio will be and thus
what the price will be roughly
so when you think about these halving
cycles obviously there's a supply shock
but how do you think about
kind of the cyclical nature of this
right is there a point where you expect
the model or ratio to be invalidated uh
either through external forces um or
people start to uh kind of price it in
and front run it like how do you think
about uh the fact that we do know the
supply and that helps for the accuracy
of uh stock to flow but at some point
does that become a negative
yeah there's several aspects to that
of course from efficient market
hypothesis you would expect
that this knowledge uh and the model
would be priced in so i actually and
most people with me expected the halving
uh the may 2020 halving would be priced
in already so we did we would not see
the actual price rise that we're seeing
now
that is
very much in line with the stock to flow
model because all the information is out
there the stock information the flow the
stock flow ratio and the model so it
shouldn't follow the model as closely as
it does today
on the other hand there's there's a lot
of people not believing the model and
the model of course hasn't proven itself
so
maybe that that sort of
puts the efficient market hypothesis
argument aside but on the other hand
i think that
the
stock to flow model will break
in the future because
one of the nice things about the stock
to flow model and especially the stock
to flow cross asset model structure x
model which also inc incorporates data
from the gold market diamond market real
estate market and silver market so other
stores of value if you will if we
um
look at that stock to flow x model
we can interpolate the data
because gold has a higher stock to flow
ratio than bitcoin and real estate has a
higher higher stock to flow ratio gold
is 60 around 60 and real estate is
around 100
where bitcoin is
50 55 right now
so we know we can within the data set we
have available with with gold and and
and real estate in there with market
values of of
10 trillion for the gold market and
hundreds trillion for a real estate
market we can we can
interpolate within the data set
and and of course that ends because if
bitcoin
will have its next halving in 2024
the bitcoin stock to throw ratio will
jump to 100 which is very cl yeah which
is approximately the same as uh real
estate
um
but after next halfing or we jump to 200
stock flow ratio for bitcoin we're out
of the model data
bounds if you will and then we have to
extrapolate which which is what
basically all the other models are doing
they're extrapolating into the future
um which is very dangerous and one of
the big assets big advantages of the
stock to flow model the stock for x
model in particular is that this
interpolation can be done so
to be in short i think
the stock to flow model
will end
to be valid somewhere
after next halving when the stock to
flow is above 100 because we cannot uh
interpolate anymore and of course that
that means probably that the dollar
the denominator in that model
will end to play a big role or or or
something and of course it doesn't say
that bitcoin will die or something it's
it's or
you know it's just the model will not be
very accurate after that for sure and
one of the things that i appreciate
about you is not only can you look at
something like the stock to flow model
and talk about kind of the cyclical
natures of the havings but also you've
got a very good understanding of market
structures uh and various things that
happen on the exchanges you had a tweet
recently talking about these cell walls
as uh kind of pure scare tactics and
we've pulled up the tweet here describe
a little bit more about what goes on uh
in these order books with these cell
walls and how folks are using them as a
scare tactic
yeah what most people maybe don't know
is my background is in institutional
investment and i've been in the
institutional
investor roles uh
my entire life so i um started at a
daily dealing room in ethics trading
then went to banking balance sheets and
and insurance balance sheets and lately
my latest job was uh managing a pension
balance sheet with the team
uh and that balance sheet was 100
billion uh us dollars approximately so
i yeah i spent my life chasing those
those charts that you have in front
there and chasing those cell walls and
by walls
and i yeah what i noticed was that most
people are sort of scared by those big
walls those big big uh cell walls uh in
this case in in that chart
um
and and and of course the
most of the time not all the time but
most of the time these cell walls are
just there to scare people in uh
not buying or or even selling
and um
plus because they signal um well don't
come here whether
at a price level where the cell wall is
because we will
we will sell and we will keep the price
under this level but in fact what you
see in real life nine and ten times
you see that as as the price approaches
the cell wall
the cell will gets gets gets cancelled
and and moved
further away so
in this case the price uh the cell wall
will be moved at a higher price
so it's it's just scare tactics and uh i
thought it was a good thing for uh to to
to put that in the tweet for other
people to know for sure no i i think
that people really appreciate that one
uh when you start to think about whether
it's the cell walls on the order books
whether it's the stock to flow uh ratio
how do you think about what i'll call
more quantifiable metrics and analysis
with things like regulation or things
that seem to be more external to the
asset itself do you worry about that
stuff do you think about it do you
incorporate it in any way into your
analysis
i yes i certainly uh think about it and
and follow it like like a hawk uh
because the big moves in bitcoin were
were all sort of triggered by um
regulatory changes regulatory uh clarity
so i track all the important news and i
put it in the database as well
however i don't use it as an explicit
input variable in my in my models
both the
the stock flow model which only has one
input which is stock to flow ratio but
also the on chain models or the floor
models uh more technical analysis based
models they don't use
that kind of information but um
in fact
those kinds of news events it could be
regulatory news but could also be other
macro economic news um
like like el salvador adopting bitcoin
or or china banning bitcoin etc
the this this kind of news is very
difficult to predict uh once it happens
and what the impact will be is it priced
in do people expect it or not
so i regard those as trigger events um
that that create
an outlier in the model or um
and that means that there is a spike
above the model value or below the value
of the model but those are those spikes
those
those trigger events are very rare and
are very
like black swan events so they they
cause some some variation in models some
model error
but they don't
disturb the general trends in
in the models that's what i would
yeah that's how i look at it and how do
you think about your investing
philosophy do you try to trade around
the asset based on uh all the data you
look at are you just dollar cost
averaging buy and hold like like talk to
us a little bit about the philosophy
that you use given that you do have at
least a um an understanding of what some
of the data says does that change what
you do at all
yeah
um but i i'm more an investor than a
trader and certainly not a day trader so
uh
i i bought i was lucky to buy bitcoin
in
2015 and 2016 when the price was 400 500
kindish uh so so
uh those are my my my bitcoin
investments and and um
i i've told in other uh interviews as
well that i i sold
uh half of that stash in uh
well shortly after the peak in into uh
in december 2017
um
based on
stock to flow kind of models so
and and i reinvested that half that i
sell
just before i published the article
about stock to flow because i knew
we were at a very low
level compared to the stock to flow
model at that time so so in that way i i
sort of trade or
sort of try to time the uh
the peaks and and the bottoms but that's
that's on a monthly or even yearly basis
and i certainly do not trade
on an hourly basis that that being said
i am very intrigued as you know by on
chain analysis uh i do a lot of
chain analysis and i have a
great team of quants around me um that
can do all sorts of programming and the
blockchain
data
and and getting signals from there and
that's very very interesting and and
sometimes you can you can actually uh
find patterns that that are tradable on
a daily or or weekly or monthly basis so
on a shorter interval than um i'm used
to invest
and and we are
um
yeah making use of those patterns uh
with
algorithmic trading uh software so we we
write write our own uh trading software
that automatically scans for those
anomalies and and uh yeah make make use
of that and that was one of my skills
also uh in my institutional career that
uh yeah the algorithmic trading part is
is very very interesting in the bitcoin
space tell us more about the
institutional interests whatever you can
share whether it's uh organizations that
you work at or have worked at or uh just
kind of conversations with uh former
colleagues peers people you know in the
industry what's the general sense from
the institutions in terms of bitcoin uh
what they're allocating how they're
thinking about those allocations
yeah so i'm amsterdam-based i talk a lot
with uh
european investors some some us
investors but it's it's mainly a
european uh perspective that i have
well certainly the companies that i
worked were not very interested in
in bitcoin yet because mainly because of
uh regulation and and well
misinformation uh
if you will because they most of them
thought it was for criminals it was for
um
and and governments would ban it and all
that and and
and of course for an institutional party
like a bank or an insurance company
they have capital regimes
with their
central bank so they'll have to put
capital aside uh for every investment
they make if the investment is more more
risky like bitcoin they have to
um
they have to park more
uh capital for that investment and for
bitcoin it's only is it's almost one to
one so if they if they would do uh
a billion dollars in bitcoin they would
they would have to park one billion
dollars in equity as well
and and that is of course not more
doable it's more doable for um for hedge
funds so what i see is is it's not the
big institutions pension funds insurance
companies and banks that are investing
on their own balance sheet or are
interested in bitcoin but it is the
hedge funds the
family offices very much so
and commodity investors especially the
gold and
commodity investors are of course very
much into the same
philosophy that bitcoins have with uh
sound money
um
and yeah so family officers commodity
investors and um
hedge funds those those are the
the ones i see active and the other ones
are will be late as usual
and when you wake up in the morning like
what do you check first what's the data
sources that you find most valuable um
or in terms of just understanding what's
happening in the market whether it's the
short-term or long-term period
um well to be honest the price is one of
the first things uh the bitcoin price
one of the first things i check because
that's the most
yeah accurate and and timely information
if if it's the same as
as when i went to bed then nothing
happened if it's
if it has a big delta then something
happened and then i go on twitter which
i find is my the most direct and and
an accurate information source there is
because
yeah well one thing i learned is to
to not read mainstream media or watch
mainstream television or even uh
things uh
media sources like like cnn and
bloomberg or the wall street journal
that are considered the creme de la
creme in institutional investing
um
i have i've learned that with these new
uh investments like like bitcoin you
better
ditch those uh standard
sources and and go to twitter and the
experts in the field because that's the
yeah the most direct way of getting
information
yeah and when you think about portfolio
construction uh for yourself or for the
institutions maybe both um is this still
something that is like a very small
allocation or is it something that uh is
being used to like denominate the whole
portfolio or how do you just think about
the portfolio construction and any sort
of concentration uh targets
uh-huh that's a tricky question because
um
i think for institutions of course
that's very important to uh to keep the
risk profile sort of constant and within
their mandate
so they'll uh they'll have to sell
bitcoin as soon as it rises to keep to
keep the
concentration uh low and within mandate
boundaries
but with
hedge funds or family offices or
or for my own investments i don't have
those those mandates or boundaries so i
can
what i see in practice that what starts
as a small investment a a couple percent
investment in in in bitcoin soon uh
grows to a uh a double-digit
position in in
bitcoin
and
well after a few years four or five
years it it sort of dominates your
portfolio that sure is true with my my
own investments as well for sure and
then before i let my brothers ask a
couple of questions
what do you think is uh the likely price
for bitcoin by the end of the year and
do you think that the bull market ends
at the end of the year or does it carry
us into the beginning of 2022
yeah that's the most asked question that
i
i would be very very surprised
if bitcoin price would be below 100 000
dollars at the end of the year that
would
well sort of invalidate my view my
models and
that would that would certainly surprise
me i
i do think
we will
see
a price that is uh at least 135
000 uh dollars by christmas because
that's what my floor model says and uh
basically i'm using three kind of models
that that all say the same thing so
stock to flow which has a hundred
thousand on average for the entire cycle
and we're
mind you we're one and a half years into
that cycle and with below 100 000 prices
so we'll have to to spend the next two
and a half years
um markedly above 100 000 to make that
that average
and the second model i use is the
unchain stuff um that that unchanged
stuff is really good at
identifying bottoms and peaks so
uh we're now talking peaks of course so
i know quite
uh
well certain not not guaranteed but but
i i will have high high confidence in
that the unchain indicators will signal
a top and if you if we look at the
unchanged signals right now
i would say that top is at least a
couple of months say six months uh
from here so so that would be nfq1 maybe
maybe later
and then the third kind of models that i
use of course that floor model 135
a thousand that's that's not based on
stock to flow it's it's it's based on
other it's a proprietary thing but it's
not based on other stuff technical and
on chain
um
so
yeah uh and by the way that's very good
at like them like the name says on at
um indicating bottoms so
i guess we will
be above 100 000 above 135 000 at the
end of the year and then will continue
to grow
maybe towards the structural flow x
model targets 288
or even above i would not be surprised
even to see
in q1 or q2 next year
prices of uh
300 400 500 000 uh
dollars but i do think
um and and i notice you were talking
before in this show that i'm a full bull
that i'm foolbull i am right now but i'm
quite sure that there will be a time
when i switch from bull to uh to bear
like i did in at the end of 2017
and i'm
yeah to be honest i'm a bit bit of
struggling with that so i i don't
i i
i don't want to disclose it because
i want to at least disclose it
responsibly and not be
responsible for triggering the bear
market so uh people have ideas for that
i
i'm i i think they're very welcome
and and so when you think about that 288
uh
thousand dollar price i think a lot of
people have heard you say that before uh
but when you say that it could go higher
300 400 500 000
is that just pure uh kind of fomo and a
blow off top uh that drives that or is
there something else that you're looking
at that shows that hey maybe we do go
past that 288 um that the stock to flow
model has there
no no that that will indeed be a fomo
and and that will be very uh clearly
marked in the unchained um
analysis which is looking for certain
kinds of transactions that i
which i called them before but those are
fomo transactions so so if if i
if the if the algos um
uh see the the fomo kind of transactions
uh coming in then the end is near
um and yeah so so i would envision like
for example going to 500k
somewhere q2 or something and then crash
back
um
well maybe 80 percent again to
100k
have a bit of a bear market and then
continue
another cycle
starting uh
with the halfing in 2024.
going from uh 55 57 000 today to 500k
and q2 back down to 100k and then
continuing into the next halving while
it sounds crazy to uh to a lot of people
uh would be pretty consistent with uh
what we've seen in the past in terms of
volatility uh both up and down so it's
uh it's interesting to hear you say that
uh joe what questions do you have yeah
plan b thanks for doing this i know uh
i'm a big fan of yours and your models
and your analysis so i know a lot of
others are also my question would be
around uh kind of the correction that
you just spoke of right which is
we're at 57 58 000 now almost uh you're
saying that it's gonna average at least
a hundred thousand over this cycle which
is 2020 to 2024 so we obviously have to
go much higher whether it's three
hundred thousand four hundred thousand
five hundred thousand uh we'll see but
traditionally there's also been an 80
correction so is that something that you
think will in in fact happen again uh
and kind of how are you thinking about
that in the long term
yeah i i do think that's exactly what
will happen again i can be wrong but
right that's that's let me be very clear
i can be wrong but i do think that
four year cycle that is sort of uh
triggered by the halfing
is a
very real thing it has to do with the
scarcity of bitcoin that's the with the
shortage that we're seeing right now
um you know bitcoins are traded on
exchanges and and the exchanges have
some some inventory of bitcoin and then
and you can buy it you can sell it but
it's basically not on chain transactions
it's it's bitcoins that are on the
exchange and you buy them from other
sellers or you sell them to other buyers
but if you look on chain so the
bitcoins that are in cold storage that
that large investors have you can
very clearly see these these waves of
shortage and and we're in in one right
now
uh that that will
at least last another couple of months
before it's uh it's really
well out of sellers if you will but yeah
from from there
um
and whatever news will trigger it i
don't know i i do think there will be a
crash
and it could be as large as the crashes
we've seen in the past we have had three
crashes of 80
and i see no reason why we couldn't have
another one uh which of course is always
short-lived and an excellent opportunity
to buy more bitcoin but it could be
quite scary for for newcomers which is
uh
well
precisely what of course those those
cycles do they shake out people that are
leveraged that are uh investing with too
much money that are not certain of their
investment strategy that are
well
those that does you need as those really
committed hotlers if you will and
they'll rise again
john what do you think yeah plan b nice
to uh virtually meet you congrats on all
the success so far i know you reached 1
million twitter followers in just about
three years so that's that's pretty
impressive um i want to talk about your
stock to flow model real quick so you
have it projected at hitting about a
million dollars a coin by 2025 do you
believe this do you still believe it and
then if so how do we get there
yes so i i really do
think that we
have at least one more cycle to go in
the stock to flow prediction uh so yeah
that would bring bitcoin um
in in the one one million
to five million dollar range
uh and i do i really do believe that
that we're getting there so that would
be the path that we're seeing right now
we're we're going from from
57 or right now to 63 98 in november
and 35 for example or something above
that right
in in december and then
then fomo starts to kick in we go to 200
300 400 whatever and then crash and from
there we wait till the next halving and
the next halfing will be another another
important fundamental
and even maybe structural event for for
bitcoin because minor i think that's
that's what people misunderstand that
that
that it's all about the um
the supply
and and
the doubling of the the stock to flow
ratio which which which is an important
part but the other part is
that miners will have to survive that
event because their their income their
their source of income and their
a revenue stream will will half and and
they'll have to
switch to uh
to new equipment find better ways uh to
fund themselves and be much more
efficient in their business and if the
if the miners and the whole business
survives another halving that's a major
accomplishment and and and that will
trigger
uh
the next the next uh rise from
say a hundred thousand after the next
crash to
uh well 10x
20 30 x
that amount which is yeah in in the
millions indeed
it's it's pretty crazy plenty when you
start to look at this uh when most
people would hear let's say 2025 a
million to five million that feels like
it's a very uh wide aperture in terms of
outcomes help people understand why it's
so hard to pinpoint you know a million
to two million let alone one to five
million right i don't think people quite
get
um kind of this idea of even into q1 q2
of next year if your kind of thesis
plays out
you said hey 288's in the model but 300
400 500 that's a pretty big uh variation
as well so help people understand like
what drives uh that variability there
yeah i think that's an important
question and it's it's uh it's funny to
see that how
naturally and logical that that path of
bitcoin is to me and how how amazing it
can be for for newcomers and and and
traditional investors indeed uh and it's
it's the trick is to to look at it
exponentially uh so in logarithmic scale
if you will um because the it's not
about the price level it's about the
growth level the percentage growth that
is that is constant or or high at least
and maybe to to uh explain that it it
um
if you look at my my followers
which is one million now which was which
was unthinkable even a year ago let
alone two years ago so three years ago i
started with um i crossed the thousand
followers boundary um
and a a year later i crossed the ten
thousand
and then a year later so the second year
i crossed a hundred thousand and now in
the third year i crossed a million
and and and if you if you look at that
that path it's it's 10x every year or 20
every month and
so it's amazing growth and and people
start to see it when you're when you're
big but in fact it's it's it's a
constant growth of 20
per month and and yeah that was 200 000
new followers last month but it will
probably be 220
um
000 new followers next month and and
it's so that 20 is constant and the same
is with the bitcoin price bitcoin goes
uh yeah let's say at
10x every every two years uh so so 100x
every four year period and uh
that is amazing
you if yeah to hear that but if you
actually experience that or look at the
data but that's different that's but if
you experience and as i did of course
buying it for 500
and then going to four or five thousand
and now we're at 40 50 000 that's 100 x
and that and there are people that have
thousand exterior investment or 10 000 x
and that
that that constant uh growth
i guess is very uh specific to bitcoin
and uh triggered by the halving
period the scarcity that's intrinsic in
bitcoin and that makes it such a perfect
store of value and and more of more
people more and more people will
recognize this this unique property
what's the thing that uh when you look
forward you're most excited too is there
a price milestone is there a number of
entities on chain is there some sort of
uh kind of external milestone what's the
thing that you're like man when this
happens that's going to be pretty cool
i'm really looking forward to it
well on the short term i would be very
would be very nice if we hit that 63 000
mark end of this month
because i guess that that's what really
did it last time uh nailing the 47 and
43 000 last two months so 63 would be
nice of course the 100k the 100k is sort
of the make or break
from for the stock flow model so i
really hope we hit that and and i'm
quite certain
uh or not uncertain i should say uh that
we're gonna hit that
um and after that um
i think the most amazing thing
for most people and also for myself will
be
that om chain model turning red the fomo
transactions that will be detectable and
me uh
as the full bull
uh
turning uh turning bear and um
as i said i'm struggling with that how
to communicate it maybe that's the best
time to go dark
but um
yeah i think there will be a time where
we switch
from bull to bear and that of course is
is a uh
a great
a great thing uh of a model that it's
it's not
always uh
but that and you're not always a moon
boy but that you that you can
predict the downsides as well so yeah
i'm not looking forward to it
on the one hand but i i i feel it's
going to happen someday
uh later next year but yeah
very much sort of looking forward to
that moment do you have any thoughts on
a bitcoin etf and how that could either
support accelerate or be detrimental to
uh stock the flow model
yes stock to flow
etf will make bitcoin available for the
masses for for uh pop mom and
investors and yeah it will be a huge
thing for the market um
although we of course
think well you can buy bitcoin right now
why should you pay the uh the fees that
are associated with these funds but it
makes it easy for for the crowds the
hurt will be coming then and uh
that will be a big big thing so
yeah i think it's coming maybe this
month um maybe next month but it will it
will be there of course the uh
gary gansler from the sec has already
sort of notched um that that it is
possible to start a
futures a bitcoin futures etf right now
which um
which i think
has already been um receiving
applications for that at the moment so
so yeah
i would be very surprised that would not
be introduced this year
and what i also found very interesting
was that one of the applications and one
of the interviews with with one of the
future etfs bitcoin ets was that they
mentioned stock flow model as one of the
models that they're tracking
for future value and
yeah
i think that's if once you've seen that
once you've
once you understand the exponential
growth and the four year cycles yeah i
think it's it's an asset you cannot you
cannot deny
how about the macro environment things
like interest rates or quantitative
easing both in the united states and
abroad how do you think about that
affecting this is it something where uh
bitcoin just remains not correlated and
you know it's worth paying attention to
but doesn't ultimately have an effect on
price or do you think that we've seen
more correlation and therefore if
there's some sort of tapering or uh kind
of slowdown in some of those activities
that it could be negative for bitcoin
yeah i think it's very important i think
it's the uh one of the reasons that
satoshi of course made bitcoin it was
against the basement against money
printing which was uh very much uh
present in 2008 when he wrote the uh
write paper white paper in the software
because that was at the peak of the
financial crisis the global financial
crisis at the time and the white paper
was uh the bitcoin white paper was
published 45 days after the lehman
default
so yeah it's very very important it's
also one of the reasons that i started
looking from an institutional investor
point of view
towards alternative investments
because because i saw the especially in
europe of course we have negative
interest rates and that yeah that turns
your world upside down that you
yeah
school or university doesn't teach you
that so
how do you survive a negative interest
rate
environment and what does that tell you
negative interest rates so
well everybody's looking for yield and
and rates that are not negative
i started looking at alternatives and
came to
came to bit going through that so i'm
very grateful to the central bankers for
introducing quantitative easing and
negative interest rates because
otherwise i would never have found
bitcoin
um so yeah i think
what we also saw is that all the price
movement a lot of price movement
in other markets like like the stock
market like the s p 500 were
related or correlated with with
[Music]
quantitative easing and possible
tapering and and uh
yeah uh the money printing if you will
so if if money is printed that money has
to go somewhere and first it will be to
bonds uh government bonds but the
receivers of those bonds usually banks
or governments
uh will spend that money again and and
so it will end up in the hands of the
well the second layer that receives that
money and uh
and some of those those companies and
and people will buy equities real estate
and bitcoin and that's why we see all
these markets go up because there's just
too much money and in a way it's just
yeah too much money chasing few goods so
all the prices of those assets go up
asset inflation is very real these days
as
all the invest
real estate investors will notice as
well and equity investors as well so um
will the markets decouple well it seems
like it today uh or this week because
bitcoin goes up and all the other
markets are not following uh even the
altcoin markets are not uh
not following bitcoin this time so
i guess in the end um
bitcoin is the ultimate
store of value
[Music]
consistent with my stock to flow model
it is not as scarce as as as gold or
about as scarce as gold today
but not as scarce as real estate today
so real estate is one of these big
money
store values um today but in the end
bitcoin will have this the same scarcity
the same stock to flow ratio as real
estate and it will be portable and
communicatable by by by a phone line by
internet connection
so it will be better than gold and real
estate together
and once people see that the the lids
are off and we go
much higher in price than where are
today
how do you think about those other
assets right either
for your own portfolio or for those
investors is this something where let's
take real estate investors uh they begin
to see that asset appreciation they see
their rents going up they're continuing
to make more and more money and is it a
thing where like that capital eventually
will flow into bitcoin as well because
they understand store value they
understand scarcity they understand like
a hard asset uh compared to that fiat
devaluation or do you think that people
who have been investing in the analog
markets
like a real estate investor they just
have a hard time understanding buying a
virtual uh item or something that is
this like global digital decentralized
store value
yeah both points are true i think uh so
money will start to flow uh from real
estate and gold and and other
investments towards bitcoin the new
investment and and yes it is a
generational thing as well because uh
the older guys that are not used to uh
computers
they will have difficulty with
understanding um virtual assets you see
it with peter schiff i i i know a lot of
people that are like peter schiff the
old
gold bugs if you will and i was a gold
buck at the time but
people that that
that cannot program that that that that
are late in the computer
thing
they will not appreciate the virtual
aspect of bitcoin and they cannot
understand digital scarcity so they'll
they'll clamp
to to to real estate and and and their
their
trusted asset like like gold
but uh but in the end um yeah
the younger people will uh
will um will turn up and and and and
have all the money and and those are
people that have been uh teached
computers and they have been on their
iphone all day and they there's nothing
scary about digital
assets at all and and they'll that
that's what you see in family offices so
the younger generation is is pitching
about bitcoin and the older generation
is against it and and well they try one
percent and that becomes ten percent of
the allocation and and i think that's
that's how it will go and even with my
own uh portfolio i was i was like uh
well like most people diversified 25
real estate 25
equities 25 gold 25
uh new stuff alternative stuff say
bitcoin
um but that bitcoin percentage grew and
grew and you learn and you think like
well yeah i'm not gonna rebalance i'm
not gonna sell my best best running
asset to to put it into gold or
something so
or buy an extra house why should i so
yeah i think i think it will be a very
natural thing with uh generations uh the
new generations coming into power and
from a gold perspective everyone is very
interested in the kind of the flipping
right this idea that uh bitcoin's market
cap will eventually grow to be bigger
than gold's most people will point to
gold's market cap at 10 11 trillion
dollars uh and bitcoin being right over
1 trillion kind of 10 11 x one of the
things i've been very interested in is
i actually think that gold's market cap
is going to collapse uh over time and so
the flipping doesn't happen around 10 11
trillion it happens somewhere lower and
maybe that's 9 trillion maybe that's you
know 6 7 8 trillion i don't really know
where but just the idea that uh in order
for bitcoin to continue to grow we are
likely to see a collapse in gold's
market cap is that your view as well or
do you disagree
yeah i'm not a gold expert but i know a
lot of gold experts and i talk a lot
with a lot with them
so i might be wrong on the gold thing
but i agree
that i think gold will eventually
go down in
in market cap
and lose that money to uh to other
investments like real estate or bitcoin
um
what i think will
what i think the big bet that that gold
investors take is is that it will once
again
be used by central bankers as the
backing of a new world currency and that
could very well be right the the central
banks are talking of the next bretton
woods moment they are talking about a
global currency could very well be the
ims special drawing rights the ser
and and yes maybe that would be
a
currency a uh
as they are backed by gold but that's
the entire bat the entire play they're
doing so if that happens of course gold
will pump will will go up and market cap
but i don't think they're gonna do that
and i
and in fact bitcoin is much cleaner in
in um
with respect that it does not have to be
uh backed by anything it's backed by
well um
the energy uh and the mining in in
bitcoin but not by another asset and not
an account or
an accountability problem that's
associated with that
and that we see in gold for example
because yeah how much gold is there in
fort knox how much gold to the chinese
central bank how much do they really
have we don't know and and with bitcoin
it's very transparent it's all on the
blockchain and
in the end
uh from a thermo
dynamic point of view from an energy
point of view
that is so much more efficient for the
human race and i guess
yeah we will tilt towards bitcoin
because it's just better money i i tend
to agree do you think that eventually
the nation states adopt bitcoin uh and
it kind of grows to be a global reserve
currency do you think it's a currency of
the internet how do you see kind of the
ultimate destination uh for this asset
if you think it's better money
yeah i think i think uh governments will
adapt bitcoin like like el salvador did
it kind of amazes me that not other um
states have and nations have adopted it
because it's the
yeah most most logical thing to do
especially if they're under the uh
pressure and and the
regime of the imf if they're
kept on a leash uh with with debt
um which is certainly something that
most countries
will probably hate but uh but of course
the leaders of those companies will be
um greatly paid by by imf and to to keep
that status quo but yeah most countries
would be better off by
switching to something other than debt
and especially
euros dollar denominated debt so
especially in south america mid america
africa
there must be countries uh that that are
going that route
and i
following the
brazilian
trend closely because that government is
some very spectacular stuff
and i'm also following some eastern
european countries like the ukraine and
the countries that belong to
the former russia and are now sort of
more oriented to to europe or but but
not part of the european union so so
they
yeah they can they can switch to bitcoin
i think some some countries will and i
really hope that that will happen on the
other hand um i do think it's in the end
a uh thing that's not decided by states
especially in the united states
and europe
it's it's something that's also decided
by banks that um that are already much
larger larger than most states
especially um
states like the netherlands where i live
which is very small and the typical bank
is like like a multiple in size of
that small country so so companies banks
and also people um
will decide that they park their money
in bitcoin and not in
in their negative interest rate yielding
uh
saving account at the bank
and that will that will be a large and
growing force with that same exponential
uh
constant exponential that we see in the
bitcoin price or my follower count or or
some other things that go exponential
very interesting
plan b i could literally talk to you for
hours uh over the years as i've seen uh
your audience grow uh seeing you put out
more content i've just been super
impressed um and so uh i think now i
think this is true uh michael saylor
myself and you all have one million
followers my
hope is that you beat me to 2 million
because if you beat me to 2 million that
means that you've not only continued uh
but you've likely been right uh which
means that most people who are listening
to this would be very very big fans of
you so you know just from everyone else
uh and me just thank you for all the
work that you've done all the
contribution you've made to the
community it's uh it's pretty cool to
see um how somebody who literally i've
never met in person i don't know your
name i have no clue what you look like
uh i'm talking to a pseudo-anonymous
identity on the internet and uh you've
touched so many people been able to
build this large following and it's all
because of the quality of the work it
just stands on that alone
is pretty incredible so just thank you
for doing all that
well thank you very much and thank you
for that last minute boost around the 1
million as well that that really did it
and i'm going after you guys right oh
a sailor and you are above me and i sort
of calculated already that um maybe
before the summer uh at the current uh
growth rate i could be number one but
who knows well listen i'm here putting
your link uh for people to follow you on
twitter in the chat i may stop doing
that if i know you're coming for me
listen
thanks for everything man of course i
appreciate you coming on i think my
brothers uh every day they say well plan
b said so uh so they're fans as well um
anyone who uh who's listening to this
make sure you go follow him on twitter
and uh we'll talk soon my friend
thanks guys all right bye
thoughts
you already know we're going to say he's
a legend
guys
yeah that's your only thought i love how
like i want to say it was like four or
five months ago he just called his shots
he said this is what the model's
predicting for each month the closing
price and every time it hits he just
checks it off he just
every single time uh over the last two
or three months he's done it and he's
been right so far i think is the most
important part right i think uh like you
said his work stands on itself and
people don't even need to know anything
about him or who he is or anything that
he does it's just that he's uh he's been
kind of a uh positive force within the
bitcoin community and he's been right
about a lot of this stuff so i hope he's
right again uh kind of going into
year-end 135k by december would be nice
but i think it's interesting that he he
talks about
100k averaging for this cycle right
because that means you have to spend
just as much time or go just as high
over 100 that you were below it right
and we've been below 100k uh pretty
drastically actually if the all-time
high is 64 000 65 000 for uh almost two
years now so you have to say that we
have to go meaningfully higher more than
100 and he's predicting two three four
five hundred so uh i i think kind of the
top end of the range is a little
unpredictable uh but it speaks to his uh
his confidence in in his models and kind
of how much higher we're gonna go on the
count of three i'm gonna i'm gonna count
to three when we cross over 3.5 k likes
we're going to do one bigger giveaway so
we get two 250 dollars and every 500
likes but we didn't do 3 000 yet and
we're not going to have done 3.5 case
we're going to give out 500 to one
person three thousand seven hundred of
you stuck around to the end of this
thing so i'm gonna reward one of you
with five hundred dollars in bitcoin on
the count of three one two three smash
the like button
the way
to win the 500
is you're gonna go and you're gonna
tweet and you're going to say
plan b was right
that's the hashtag plan b was right but
you have to include you have to include
a screenshot of your sofi account if you
include a screenshot of your sofi
account i will give 500 to one person
who tweets out a screenshot of your sofa
account with hashtag plan b was right
and that is how somebody's going to win
500 bucks
i don't even know how much we've given
away
how much do we give away today 250 500
750 a thousand with the 500 including
the 500
yeah 12. it will be 17.50 oh john's on
the numbers john johnny numbers is over
there johnny led nothing okay to smile
smile nothing smile you good john smile
no you can't smile
we're gonna have a new system next week
without these giveaways
john wants everyone to know that there
is uh that the giveaway is just part of
the process that following up with
everyone and actually getting them the
funds and tracking people down and
getting their address and all this stuff
is another part and we appreciate john
taking care hey john we appreciate you
appreciate you we appreciate your smile
there it is
pam and bitcoin john you're the mvp of
this show you are now officially the
only person who has been here we had me
joe jordy matt you pelina everyone was
vying for it but john is the last
undisputed king he's the only
the iron man he's the only iron man here
on this show non-stop every single day
i'll give you a patch on it there you go
there you go all right all right all
right but you're still gonna have to
pick the person on twitter for the
giveaway all right so
go to twitter screenshot us your uh
sofia account use hashtag plan b was
right we'll pick one person tomorrow
we'll let you know who won 500 bucks
everyone else chill out we're gonna get
to you we'll get you the money we know
come back tomorrow tell your friends
tell your wife tell your brother your
sister your cousin your mom your uncle
your dog your pet snake your side chick
or your what do you say girlfriend's
father-in-law or your wife's
father-in-law's girlfriend's
father-in-law's brother's uncle's cousin
that owns a laundry mat his
employees okay go tell them tune into
the show tomorrow make sure that you
like the video make sure you are
subscribed to the channel we say 250 000
subscribers we're going for a million
who gets there first us or bitcoin i'm
willing to bet we get there way before
bitcoin does but who knows you know
we'll see maybe we should get
interesting could we raise bitcoin to
500k
probably we'll probably get there first
make sure you subscribe to the channel
we appreciate you guys all tuning in
every single day
that's it thank you appreciate y'all see
you guys again tomorrow big show again
tomorrow
big show
[Music]